هذا وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان الوضع
الحدوديه بين البلدين بات مستقرا قادع
المتحدث باسم الخارجيا نيودلهي الى
الابقاء على حوار مفتوح بشان هذه القضيه
فان الوضع الحدوديه بين الصين والهند
مستقر بالمجمل لقد حافظ الطرفين على حواري
دون عراقيين بشان المساله الحدوديه عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
على غرار الصين من اجل التنفي
لتوافق مهم توصل اليه قاده الطرفين
والالتزام بشكل صارم بروح الاتفاقيه
الموقعه من الجانبين والمحافظه معا على
الامن والهدوء في المنطقه الحدوديه بين
الصين الهند
رئيس تحرير صحيفه مالي جلسات معنا
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه الدراسات
الدوليه في شنغها ابدا معك سيد دينج لونج
سيد الخارجيه الصينيه تقول ان الو بات
مستقرا على الحدود بتقدير الكم سيصمد هذا
الاستقرار
يعني
اشتباكات بين
الجيشين بسبب عدم وجود يعني وحدود رسميه
باين
يعني دائما
ومرور الجيش
احول الى او تحول الى السيد ظفر الاسلام
خان فيما ذكر سيدنا عن الحوار سيد ظفر
الاسلام خان الخارجيه الصينيه تتحدث عن
ضروره ابقاء الحوار مفتوحا كيف ترد نيودله
على ذلك
نعم الهند تريد ان ان يبقى الحوار مفتوحا
وقد سبق في سبتمبر الماضي بالاشتباك بين
الجانبين في شرق لداخ اغبى 16 جلسه بين
البلدين وهذا الذي حدث في دقيقه حدث يوم 9
ديسمبر الحالي حسب قول وزير
الدفاع الهندي السيد رئيس اليوم في
البرلمان ولكنه لم يشرع كثيرا عندما قال
ان كان هناك اشتباك بالايدي بين الجانبين
وان بقى عدد من الجرحى ولكن لم يقع شخص
الجندي هندي قتيلا
الحقيقه ان استخدام البنادق همم متفق عليه
بين البلدين بانه ممنوع في هذا المكان
ولذلك كان الاشتباك بالهراوات وبالعاسيه
فقط
الجانب الهندي المصادر الهنديه ليس
الحكومه ولكن المصادر الانديه تقول
ان 300 جندي صيني دخلوا من دقه من المفترض
انها من دقه هنديه واجاهم 70 جنديا هنديا
وبقا هذا الاشتباق بالهرامات والعسي همم
بغض النظر عن من بدا بهذه المناوشات او من
الطرف
البادئ والمعتدي فيها هذه المناوشات تتكرر
مره تلوى الاخرى ما افاق الحل ما هي السبل
الحل
هذه المشكله قائمه منذ استقلال الهند حين
طلبت الصين من الهند عدم الاعتراف
الانجليز وهم الصينيون يقولون ان الانجليز
فرضوا هذا الخط لانهم كانوا يمثلون القوه
الصين على قبول هذا
بل
دخولنا نتمسك بخدمهن ولكن هذا الخط غير
معين في دقيقه وهناك تقريبا ثلاثه الاف
440 كلم همم من الحدود مما هو غير متفق
عليه
ويسمى
الفعليه ولكن ليس هو ليس هناك حدود همم
متفق عليه بخصوصا في هذا الوقت الوقت
الشتاء يكون هناك همم من الجانب الهندي
الجانب الهندي يقول ان ال- ال- جنود
السنيون يحاولون اختراق همم المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها الهند في المنطقه
السابق ترامب كان قد
عبر عن رغبته في وساطه بين البلدين ما
امكانيه وسط الدوله ثالثه في هذا النزاع
الحدودي
في هذا يعني
همم
اجنبيه
في الحوارات
حدود متفق عليها
هناك
وقدود طويله بين البلدين
ومعناه
قواعد تصرف
الى مصر
شكرا لك سيد دانج لونج استاذه العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه الدراسات الدوليه في
شنغهاي وشكر موصول للسيد ظفر الاسلام خان
رئيس تحرير صحيفه